[Music]
this week we've got full view please try
and nice fight samurai life Joe never
mind best night as I've seen the article
I know but when you guys wait the next
clip is off the record
yeah but not for you guys okay unless
they stay yeah my other hand on so I
couldn't do it we forgive you
yeah for our first story oh we have one
man this man in Santa Rosa California he
had he was forced to cut down the sides
of a fence like he recently put up
that's wine country right Santa Rosa
continued he had a cut down all plants
he built this six foot tall fence to
keep his two dogs in his yard make sense
$9,000
yups and a neighbor filed a complaint
with the city saying that it obstructed
the view when he was spying on him in
the shower so his name is Jason this is
Jason yes tom he's a blood to protest he
put a whole bunch of naked mannequins in
his yard because now everyone could see
inside his yard so he was like oh you
want to see inside well then here you go
and so he's set up like a little tea
party he's a blood dude that's weird
this is the fence he got the cut is down
in half oh oh oh that's awesome moving
company so he's wearing like his moving
company like the city actually side
his neighbors huh the city sided with
his neighbors
maybe there's a city ordinance what
neighbors oh that sucks
well usually the the nice thing to do
when you build a fence is to kind of
tell your neighbor that's affected
that's true because when we when my
brother built a fence we went and hit up
the neighbor behind us and everyone
that's affected by so just watch this
fool is like a block away and he's like
I don't like it when I Drive by well the
thing is so his house is in a corner
that's why because they go to a stop
sign and then they say that they can't
see the oncoming traffic that's why like
legally like he can't have this fence or
that the neighbor that complain is
always wearing all blue man you don't
know what his real intentions are he
owns a different moving company ya know
he's a [ __ ] tip yeah yeah I know that
you're saying it was a crib but I was
just saying like adding to it that he
also worked she was trying to yes and I
know have moving companies that's
stealing companies - no he's a [ __ ] tip
that's freaking crazy
all right vehicle never yes and just
doesn't I think we did a great job
oh thank you a great job in another
dimension yeah yesterday I sent her
yesterday I said to the cauchy it's not
off the record oh gosh oh that was
pretty funny no they don't see she goes
oh just set out the call she please
respond to the email confirm see you
tomorrow
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you too [ __ ] but
she was giggling on the other side when
she got it but yeah so here's the full
magnitude they said that they were at an
anatomically correct so I was like one
nipples and everything I can't believe I
guess this fool can afford those type of
man you know so this these mannequins
were leftover from one of his moving
dogs oh they didn't want that's why I
mentioned Nikita's house look even extra
trash yeah I was like I was like if you
could afford that you could afford a
lawn mower too bro like [ __ ] look at
that jungle back there if if people
really can't see because of that fence
and there's a stop sign and it's a
safety hazard yeah it makes sense and he
looks bad now totally but if it was just
an [ __ ] neighbor that's a control
freak
that's different what he's like eight
feet tall god damn ginormous I know yeah
so then he left one of the seats empty
and then put a sign on it saying
reserved for the nosy neighbor that
complained about me oh my gosh just
would never want to see his backyard
it's so unpleasant right yeah I mean it
looks like chaos it looks like [ __ ]
what do you what's that [ __ ] that the
[ __ ] Walking Dead that's what it
looks like
post-apocalyptic yeah it really does I
know that's some tall grass there but
now the city said like healthy grass
it's all green true it's been raining
yeah so they did when they first gave
him the notice they said that he will be
charged a fine of $500 every day that
the fence remains in its original
condition so that's why he was like
forced to chop it down in half and then
he went full petty 500 bucks every day
every day he spent $9,000 on building a
fence that would be so they said alright
if you want your pen know you don't have
to go to the city to build fences no we
did we did it ours I'm gonna go to the
city no one ever does anything I think
your back fence I think yeah I think
front the front fence oh there is no
front fence
wait no no no that's what I'm saying cuz
that looks like a like more of a it's
kind of front because it's probably
exposed to the fire like their limits
yeah they're building limits like
anything taller than this you might have
to yeah so that's what I was wondering
if was there like there was probably
city code it was a six inch
I'm sorry six yeah but then the city
said if you still want your fence the
way you have
you have to move at 15 feet Oh cuz it's
a obstructing view right makes sense so
like if he went to the city and got it
approved it wouldn't be the lot oh yeah
oh yeah mmhmm yeah but now that much
smaller yeah viral and then so he's
saying that all of the neighbors have
been giving him nothing but compliments
this is a scared problem no funny I know
cuz he looks scary
maybe lot of people are like I can see
the stop sign just fine a probably a
better solution could have been him
talking to his neighbor is like well hey
what if I just buy one of those huge
circular reflective things so we could
see the stop sign is that okay instead
it'd be like [ __ ] you homie oh my cuz
she didn't have homie then I'll put
these naked people here homie you know
maybe that might have been in good soul
or maybe a 12-foot wide stop sign a
bigger one man if you's getting fined
500 bucks a day I cut that [ __ ]
immediately yeah of course he did a
really good job cutting it down to that
it's all pretty [ __ ] laser cutter
look how crisp that is really nice cut
from far away it's not as straight as it
looks everybody don't change the title
of the article to that it's not cook
advanced he didn't use a trapezoid man
alright for our next story a video of a
man trying to board a bus with an ATM
machine went viral an ATM machine I will
show it to you right now so this
happened in New Jersey funny how people
say ATM machine but it's like machine
machine sure totally
but one says ASA ASA's what are you
saying like nah dude I'm all right claim
that is his this was like hold up I
didn't steal this I promise I didn't
steal this whole she's not letting him
in that's the [ __ ] federal crime to
go to jail for like 25 years plus he's
gonna do this to me
[Music]
that was their production company on the
other side it's a Wayans movies know
what the problem you know you know how
done this guy is like I don't know if
people notice he's literally trying to
stop a bus with one hand go away what is
you putting heavier how the bus going to
do like it was gonna stop immediately
guys see how offended he got that the
bus didn't bus driver didn't want to
split with him he's gonna do this to me
yeah this guy's just [ __ ] smoking a
ball of crack and he's coming down hard
yeah so this went viral on Twitter when
this person named Darius posted it and
captioned it with everybody wanted to be
rich but nobody want to help you get it
no right that's what he's gonna split it
with him he's like I'm so generous
like I believe these people but what
made him think he was gonna get away
with it
he's coming down off crack I mean I
guarantee you he had to be on Droid does
that mean coming up what happens mean
you're coming in here you get desperate
because you're you're you're withdrawing
yeah so that's when people different
kind of withdraw that's when people do
the most time
that ATM humor yes we hadn't even get
money out of that without doing it the
right way you slash it yeah you probably
destroyed I don't know
because actually like tight tight I'm
pretty sure you have to just unscrew
some parts yeah I have no idea really I
don't know your background I'm pretty
sure it's built like to be
indestructible I have no idea yeah that
guy's an idiot cuz he try to lift it and
put it in a bus in the first place 360
spin he did oh we've all done s it was
great well I've done that before one
movie like a fridge into a new apartment
yeah well things by ourselves
yeah just sucked you know it's like I
can see about that recently I'm like oh
you know it's weird like no one none of
our friends if we don't give each other
every well moving help or right right
does that that used to be the thing cuz
we're we're we are real friends now like
48 but now it's like we could just get a
little bright not bother anybody to I'm
like that's maybe helping your friends a
lot it's like an early twenties thing I
don't know I always cuz you're broke but
yeah the reason why cuz Hoover did like
it was around back then but we're too
broke to afford it and if I had if I had
money back then I would just say get a
cabin I'll pay for right yeah because
I'm not I've been better friends if we
actually help each other we would know
cuz I do I do have some friends I still
have some friends that aren't in like
the social media world so they kind of
still there's like a regular life and
even though they can easily pay for like
a pain or whatever if they need a paint
they just invite friends to come over
and there's still like a hard like oh
yeah I'll buy some beers and let's just
paint my house together what do you
think about it right if your work is
done at five and then your weekends you
don't work it's easy to do it yeah it
was like what are you guys doing nothing
let's get together have a potluck paint
the house make it an event so for us
it's like whoa can I blog there
yeah yeah can i vlog me helping you yeah
yeah I'm trying to relax
I'm trying to [ __ ] sleep yeah I feel
bad asking people for help me cuz I'm
like if I'm busy how busy are you then
oh we don't build bonds that way though
well I mean because like a punch each
other the face it's like it's like if I
do have time I don't want to do work
with you I want to just [ __ ] chill
let's go vacation let's do something
let's do something else where we're not
working but then if we're doing an
activity like I don't want it to be a
chore I want it to be like a hobby so
it's like let's get together and have a
like a cook-off or like let's do
something yeah like let's go let's go
watch a fight with your friends you're
gonna fool anybody we're like she's
having fun over there you don't cook
with your friends yep I gotta cook off
like who can make the best pot not
competitive with your friends no we have
like the biggest pot Luck's do know it's
like competition like friendly
competition never participate in that
competition we like to we don't even
like to eat it we just we just chill do
you like when I went to be honest M
foods oh it wasn't as simple as a she'll
call instant chef that I was on and this
dude was making like gumbo at home ah if
you wanna make the gumbo again dude yeah
oh god that's three what No
he just thought about food he's mad to
talk about the food gumbo sounds off
david's gumbo is something that we
always used to do fourth of july know
what's been happening finite so why
would you call me out and [ __ ] I gotta
like you the episode where everyone just
cry cry off Joe I love you know it's
gonna have a cry off right now I know
hey I was just putting you on the spot
for life on camera and I'm like that
damn it what the [ __ ] dude you know why
you guys don't get invited right now
give me a [ __ ] break
I'm trying to separate I'm just trying
to separate fun from real and I can't
even do that cuz you're reminding me
right now give me a break all right
[ __ ] balls
I invite you guys now Gio just [ __ ] it
up for everybody if we get it I think
she didn't want to jinx it way to make
it all real yesterday we're gonna say
we're talking to someone were like
should we tell someone we were was your
mom we were
when you're when you're the pink oh
we're talking sit we're vlogging and
we're like should we tell the vlog that
we put it then I'm gonna put an offer
she don't don't cheeks it cuz you don't
like in LA it's so competitive so we
just want to leave it in the air and see
if we get it but I guess she and that
she actually told the camera well no I
told you guys and you guys officially
jinxed if it's on camera and they be
trying to move into a house I know
[Laughter]
oh no I couldn't have done that last
week I couldn't help everyone's doing
alright hope people are doing okay cuz
we're all not there was a machete fight
during a robbery and again you know
that's the worst people got but [ __ ] my
pace with oh my god that's the worst
that is the movers Sundays at our house
huh you said it like you put on eyeliner
and then you actually put a dot right
there oh that's because it's just really
sad that's you don't say it like that
that's that's not how the phrase works
something marry all right now don't you
hate when this just happens god damn
machete play Oh both have one where is
this that everyone carries a [ __ ]
machete Alabama they both have machetes
yeah wait does he have a fake gun in his
pocket
wait why would you wait why would you
have a gun ana machete no he's
pretending to have a gun so like scare
the dude cuz now the dude has that
machete the guy that works at the gas
station oh that guy's not scared bro why
is that guy I would have started
chopping away wait what does he have in
his hair machete
thank you I'm saying why would you have
a machete and a gun doesn't make any
sense does it miss pretending pretending
oh and he keeps pulling his hand out of
the way who was the robber robber and
then the guy wearing the white shirt
works at the gas station so he locked
the door to lock him in there but now
he's tearing it down doors stabbing and
then this woman is with the RO my god
it's like he's like you know Robin
that's I go for the tire we've hired
Harvey yeah or attending yeah
Jackie hurt now he's jacking fair car
how the turntable turntable so the girl
is also a robber yeah oh yeah sure a
robber robber ass it's not real robber
the silky bra in the business sun-lee
anyway that it's 33 and set this 32
that's obsessed he's the Robert what he
doesn't even look like a robbery Lanie
oh she doesn't okay so what happened was
in the video you guys saw how he locked
him in like a Mormon wife he likes it
she does and so when the attendant went
outside to if I would Lanie and started
messing up the car that's when Seth went
back in and pulled money out of the wife
God they both got away they drove away
but as like you could see in the video
when the tenant was in the backyard and
with the machete he was on the phone
with the police so the police already
knew they were on their way
a witness saw this whole thing happen
and then followed them over to a Burger
King and then the cops caught the but
cuz all that Robyn got caught him hungry
stupid
yes need a whopper baby they only
suffered minor non-life-threatening cuts
so tell them a machete fight that's
pretty crazy Alabama that's yeah but
this is regular curse for you so I don't
know what you're I mean that's the worst
how often do you have two machetes like
going back
everyone carry a machete here they're so
cheap on Amazon you can get like $14 man
really yeah is they're pretty cool is
the black one too when you're like
gardening huh well camping well if you
get a cold steel one they're expensive
but they're worth the price but people
use it for gardening a ship but I got it
for camping cuz cuz it does chop like
branches really David me going on safari
adventures I know well this was last
year when I was just buying stuff for
some stupid reason and I was really into
that show [ __ ] naked and afraid so I
thought to myself in case I'm making an
afraid you have a machete I forget to
grab clothes but you don't forget the
machete just to let you know
[Music]